the Joe Rogan experience unless they get
rid of mosquitoes there will always be
and I think that is a possibility that's
something they've talked about doing is
engineering some new kind of mosquito
that like doesn't breed or some mosquito
that kills other mosquitoes or or
something along those lines they've had
a couple of different things that
they've tried to figure out how to do
but the problem is you don't once you do
that you know you let that cat out of
the bag and kill all the mosquitoes then
you find out the mosquitoes with a glue
that holds the whole thing together and
the lizards were eating the mosquitoes
and the cats are eating the lizards who
knows what kind of [ __ ] could go down
got rid of mosquitoes yeah but they do
carry a lot of disgusting things the
dirty blood yeah the dirty saliva its
sting you and give you a malaria disease
oh dude people were worried remember
when aids first came out people were
worried that mosquitoes we're gonna pass
it around oh yeah definitely people like
what they carry malaria why the [ __ ]
can't they carry that well that's the
thing about all these pandemics is like
you know coronavirus is actually kind of
a [ __ ] I mean it's it's easy to kill
there's other viruses which are much
tougher but as a very thin membrane it's
it's a fatty membrane that goes over it
yeah and you know foam from soap yeah by
the way make sure when you wash your
hands get a lot of foam going that's
actually the thing that kills the corona
really yeah foam yeah foam it up and get
your thumbs for God's sake don't forget
your goddamn thumbs it's a new strain of
corona virus not previously seen in
humans for other strains interests are
very common it usually only calls mild
symptoms like the common cold yeah yeah
what we're just talking about we're
talking about washing hands malaria then
it's that it's a [ __ ] that's what was
because there was this other thing that
I talked about with the Austral home
that scared me way more than that that's
uh I mean it's scary
for sure don't get me wrong but there's
this chronic wasting disease that they
found in deer and it
it's 100% fatal and it's a prion disease
the same same kind of disease as mad cow
disease was and the same as mad cow
disease made the jump to humans then it
became very dangerous and people to some
people to this day like they can't give
blood because they were alive eating
cheeseburgers during the mad cow days
maybe they've released that I don't know
but for a long time they couldn't get
blood because the idea would be that you
still these prions in your system you
could they took these surgical
instruments that they used on patients
who died of mad cow disease and they ran
these surgical instruments through these
sanitization machines the sanitary
process sanitizing process three times
three times like a thousand degree
temperature couldn't kill it three times
still had living prions on the surgical
equipment damn yeah and all we got to do
is soap it up sing happy birthday twice
yeah the sign nothing in comparison to
something that could happen to us if
chronic wasting disease ever made the
leap from deer to humor yeah it's very
spooky and I've I had my friend Doug
Dern and Brian what's his name again
don't guess Richard I think I think
you're right
who's biologist who's explaining who's
explaining a wildlife expert explained
all of it to us like what what it is how
it's happened how its spread it's
spreading from deer and do the end is
horrific we watched a video of one of
them where they're they're wasting away
and they're spitting so this this this
this fluid that's coming out their body
is contaminated and then deer will come
along and eat the leaves that have that
prion on it and take it in and ill get
it it'll get chronic wasting disease and
it'll rot away and spitting out this
stuff that other deer not dude it's
horrific
and it's 100% fatal so think about what
we've got that your immune system you
know for the vast majority of the people
is going to fight off it's tragic the
people that don't not diminishing that
at all that's not what I'm saying but
there's a giant difference between
something that idris elba gets and shows
no weaknesses it shows no symptoms
rather or Tom Hanks and Rita Wilson get
it and they get over it it's rough but
they get over and they survive versus
prions that kill hundred percent of all
the deer that they in fact they're all
dead and they waste away the waste away
to nothing it's it's ugly Wow look this
guy was was sounding the warning bell he
was like these have made the jump to
mice and they prions have made the jump
from animals to people this is totally
possible
this can happen yeah and it's like right
now it's like this like silent thing
that they're just keeping an eye on and
it's spreading across the country and
people don't know like there's places
where people have stopped eating deer
meat and there's checkpoints we have to
bring the deer in like Wisconsin where
my friend Doug lives where they bring
the deer and they have to test them
before you can eat this vid chronic
wasting just test it for a CWD yeah and
the thing is it hasn't made the jump to
people but who's gonna take that risk
Yeah right
you're gonna eat it eat this deer
sausage that came from a deer that has
CWD but it's never made the jump to
people so have the sausage hmm like what
I'm not eating that the thing definitely
had it it was definitely positive
because a lot of times they're positive
like a year so they're running around
like looking like a regular deer and you
shoot it and you cook it neat and you're
eating to prions yes they just don't
affect your brain yet about 7,000 to
15,000 animals infected with CWD are
eaten each year and that number could
rise by 20% annually according to the
Alliance for Public wildlife which Oscar
Holmes cited in his testimony scientists
can't say for sure that CWD will
crossover and infect humans but as time
goes on and more infected meat is
consumed the likelihood increases
osterholm said it's like a throw at the
genetic roulette table he said [ __ ] that
yeah what if that gets into the cows
what if that gets into your cheeseburger
this is maybe what the whole vegan
movements about maybe they're trying to
protect us from an ultimate attack what
if that's the only people that survive
can you imagine how annoying the earth
will become everybody will be thin and I
know well for self righteous all the
guys would have to have man buns
you have to yeah meat-eaters would like
get a Velcro man bun and put it on just
to get through security yeah you got it
you couldn't eat meat anymore everybody
was dying of chronic wasting disease
yeah imagine man again this is uh these
are possible
[Applause]